i don't think it was in my mind about oh
i'm getting nervous if
i win or they don't call my name i mean
i was getting nervous that
that times that time's coming here are
the nominees
for performance by an actor in a leading
role i realized that right before
they were calling out the the names of
the possible best actors
oh my name's the only one that starts
with an m
if you hear the words um that would be
great news
and the oscar goes to i laid my head
back i think i was looking up
and uh uh i heard
matthew mcconaughey i had quite a
release right then i mean
of joy uh probably some tears
and then moved up that wonderful
position to be able to move up that
stage and accept
an award given to me by my peers people
that i admire whose work i admire
said yep excellent work excellent
craftsmanship
yes a plus first thank you to the other
nominees
all these performances were impeccable i
remember not having any speech it would
be a bit of arrogance or coup de gras to
have something written
it was like now that's not for me to do
that's a little presumptuous
first off i want to thank god because
that's who i look up to
to my family that's who and what i look
forward to
and to um my hero
that's who i chase i'm chasing me in 10
years my hero's me in 10 years that's a
form of the first one
of someone to look up to but it's for me
it's the mortal version of who am i
going to become
my hero's always 10 years away i'm never
going to be my hero
i'm not going to attain that i know i'm
not and that's just fine with me because
that keeps me with somebody
to keep on chasing so those three things
i
say all right all right all right you
know that's the call back
to the very first three words i ever
said
on film for what i thought may be a one
night hobby that i'd never do again
which turned out to be 29 years later a
career that i love
i'm honored to sign off with that now
because it calls back to a beginning
for me so to any of us whatever those
things are whatever it is we look up to
whatever it is we look forward to and
whoever it is we're chasing to that i
say amen
to that i say all right all right all
[Applause]
[Music]
right
you